what is going on there citizens of the reject
Nation they have just dropped from Universal
Pictures the Five Nights at Freddy's teaser
trailer as excited as I am for this to come
from Blum House I want you guys to leave a
like for Universal Pictures who just blocked
our Super Mario's brother's movie reaction
they have a fantastic reputation from every
single YouTuber for being the easiest to work
with when it comes to copyright we follow the
guidelines that we do for every movie reaction
and undoubtedly Universal is consistently the
easiest ones to constantly work with even though
we know you'll eventually Let It Be public you
just love to have some fun with us don't you
we didn't cover the Oppenheimer trailer due
to the fact for how easy they are to work
with but we're gonna take another chance
here because it's Five Nights at Freddy's
so leave a like for Universal Pictures
[Music]
welcome to Freddy Fazbear's pizzeria where fantasy
and fun come to life hit it
guys oh this is perfect oh
oh [__] Josh Hutcherson's assistant that's right
oh hell yeah those security cameras
we're going to have so much fun together
whoa I want to play a game
I need some crappy Pizza
oh give me more wow oh dang I wanted more well
you know even though Universal put us on the
Press list and they email us every single trailer
hopes we will react to every one of their trailers
we know that they're going to be so easy with us
featuring it in a video it's like the publicity
team would want us to isn't that ironic scheme you
know this is how they're going to make all their
money back on the movies by collecting these
YouTube earnings we're gonna put all that not
shade to the side this movie looks really really
fun you know a lot of people don't know this about
me but all of my friends my wife and especially
would know this I'm a huge Chuck E cheese fan
still love Chuck E cheese to this day sometimes
we do go on a date to Chuck Cheese Five Nights
at Freddy's is a very compelling concept to me in
general I've dabbled with the game a few times I'm
not the biggest knowledgeable guy I don't want to
sell the best maybe it's not like I know some of
it I don't know any of it really I've only played
the game like a handful of times which is a lot
of fun I think I did a let's play on that cyber
Channel Once forever ago the footage that we're
getting here yeah this looks like a big step up
from Willie's Wonderland and it has this blend
of like good old traditional Blum House type of
Punchy horror the animatronic effects look cool
I got saw Vibes and certain elements of it looks
like we are going to be getting rich with the lore
of how this all came to be because it has a blend
of Wick and feel like torture horror combined with
an element of like Supernatural lore horror as
well are you picking up on these Vibes are we on
the same page on the same page my anger that has
filled me moments before filming this it slowly
disabling to me yeah take it away John ah yeah
no this is looks uh like what you would want from
Lily's Wonderland like I'm very curious about the
saw elements because I am not the greatest expert
however a good friend of mine shouts out to Erica
if you're watching this is a five nights fanatic
and through her I've come to know at least bits
and pieces of the lore and I think one thing that
separates this because Willie's wondering and
obviously comes to mind with the Banana Splits
because they beat you to the movie punch but here
I think part of the big perils is going to be kids
involved because one thing about Five Nights
at Freddy's is there's like a bunch of really
sick lore and backstory about like kids who have
gone missing and who's like corpses are twisted
and tied up inside the Machinery I mean I don't
know if they're going in that area of the Lord
but there's certainly a good potential to get icky
and gross and unsettling here and I feel like you
know in Willie's Wonderland or something like that
you had a bunch of young people in Nick Cage words
here you got Josh Josh Hutcherson and then what
looks to be a few children so I don't know like it
looks like it has the punch and the grit and the
horror of something aimed a little bit more at the
R-rated crowd but at the same time this is like a
a game with a huge fan base of young people yeah
so I feel like they're gonna have to go as like
hard PG-13 is possible with this well I that makes
me wonder based off of what you said Universal
sucks by the way but based off of what he said I
wonder if that's why they actually decided because
I feel like this movie will be rated R isn't the
Creator like someone who is like really beloved
still yes I thought there's like a trouble with
the the creator of Five Nights at Freddy's I I
don't remember well it doesn't matter um he did
something I totally forgot what he did I remember
he got in a lot of trouble and he decided to
like leave the IP behind in some way I completely
forgot but for all my friends who like did videos
on Five Nights at Freddy's like oh I'm getting
uncomfortable about covering five nights I don't
remember any of the specifics sure but I wonder
if that's why they decided to do a dual release
with this as well I mean I know while that worked
out for Halloween we are in a day and age now
where it seems like you can be confident enough
to release a movie in the theaters and then at
least wait 45 days for it to come out on streaming
to get blocked on YouTube so you know God damn it
but we'll be there yeah we'll be there they always
let it go come on just like why why put us through
having to fight and read and then you eventually
let it let us go it has everyone at the movies and
every YouTuber I know complains about it I wonder
if they they decided like yeah let's still do it
even though that's something we don't have to do
but that would allow the kids to maybe still get
access to watching it as well they can just borrow
their parents account sure I mean they probably
know they will like this is even though Five
Nights at Freddy's has a huge kids fan base it's
not some I wonder if there are some parents who
are like maybe I shouldn't have let my kids get
like so uh endowed with this and maybe you know
sometimes they do it is like you know the kind of
subject matter that for a lot of kids like parents
to kids relationships they probably wouldn't want
them to get super involved with it I'm not
saying every pair I'm sure a lot of parents
like don't give a [__] but I think that it is
that kind of subject of the kids like secretly do
like get involved with it well my wife you know
she's worked at many schools and yeah she's like
many students are like obsessed with yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah because there's so many different
animatronics in the different locations and stuff
but two two I mean I think the game is deceptive
and that you are limited often to the flashlight
and the security cameras and then you have all the
lore kind of happening around that so you know you
can have a parent walk by and just be like ah you
know It's a Spooky Little pop-up game but that's
also what makes me wonder about this are we gonna
get like one a la you know the Doom movie where
it's like there's one first person POV sequence
just like the game are we gonna get a security
camera mode but but I'm like is that gonna be
just one scene where it's like oh we're flipping
the security cameras or is that going to be like
a full movie mode I think it'll just be one scene
probably I think it would get really boring and
old fast and then when it happens the crowd will
lose their [__] and then stand up and Applause
at the movie theater and then go praise Universal
for bringing them to life thank you Universal and
make sure this doesn't end up on any reactions
is that Matthew Lillard it looks like Matthew
yes I believe it is this is the ironic part about
Five Nights at Freddy's trailers I know they want
people to do reactions to this and they're gonna
claim every single one so that is the most best at
least commit to not having any coverage whatsoever
of this variety it is it is the most they just are
notorious for this like this is again this is the
prime kind of property aimed at the prime kind of
audience who's gonna come to these sorts of videos
and get hyped up I can't wait for that manual
claimant to review this video hey buddy how you
doing I hope you're having a great day wonderful
company hope you get a raise I hope your boss sees
all the people you claimed and is like you know
what we need more you around and Freddy looks cool
no this looks fun looks fun little goofy little
cheesy looks like what you want from Five Nights
at Freddy's like even from The Limited knowledge I
have of it uh this looks like what I want because
I I don't know how crazy lore heavy it'll go like
this one just has to be effective but they if this
one succeeds they have a good franchise on their
hands this is like franchise opportunities
franchise Prime all right guys we'll leave
your thoughts down below be sure to subscribe
leave a like what's your favorite Universal
Property and uh we'll catch you guys soon I'm
late for an event that I gotta go to [Music]